this video is sponsored by squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
hey guys this is vadim with max tech and
this right here
is apple's brand new m1 ipad pro and
this
is samsung's tab s7 plus now the big
thing that we want to compare in this
video
is apple's brand new mini led display
which is a bit controversial
because of the blooming issues compared
to the oled display on the tab
s7 plus which has pixels that illuminate
themselves so they don't have blooming
issues
but they do have their own limitations
which we are going to get into
and on top of that we're going to be
comparing everything else such as the
speakers
design cameras and of course the
performance because this ipad pro
has a new crazy m1 chip now starting off
with the design even though the samsung
is a 12.4 inch tablet compared to 12.9
inch you guys can see a
massive size difference between the two
this one's just so much wider and that's
because of the aspect
ratio that i'm going to be talking about
when we get into the display section
and because of that the ipad pro weighs
1.5 pounds compared to 1.3
so you could definitely tell the
difference in your hand and on top of
that the samsung is actually a little
bit thinner as well
now taking a look at the other design
aspects we can see antenna bands along
both the ipad pro
and the samsung except the samsung also
has it on the bottom
and we also see that we have a wireless
charging kind of plastic insert for the
s
pen whereas the ipad pro has it on the
side but in this video we're not going
to get into the pens and the keyboards
because we have a ton of other stuff to
cover
like the displays and performance now i
do want to mention that both of these
have
wide and ultra wide cameras on the back
along with flash
but the ipad pro does have a dedicated
lidar scanner the ipad pro also has
a thunderbolt port for the first time
ever compared to only usbc on the
samsung
and that is going to be a big deal for
some people who really like using those
accessories
and both of these also have quad
speakers so you have the speaker grilles
on
both sides now before i flip these over
and we get into the very interesting
stuff
let me first give a shout out to the
sponsor of this video squarespace
if you've been thinking about making
your own website squarespace is
seriously the best way to go
you can build a great looking website
like we did with literally no web making
experience
it doesn't matter if you want a
portfolio a blog e-commerce or
anything else you simply choose a
template customize blocks of text and
images
and then easily move them around it's
incredibly simple affordable and ours
have been running flawlessly for over
three years
bringing in lots of traffic thanks to
its built-in seo tools
start your free two-week trial with no
credit card required by going to
squarespace.com
maxtac or use our custom link below when
you're ready to launch to save 10
on your first purchase of a website or
domain now let's go ahead and flip these
over and i've got to say that one thing
that i really love on the ipad is
face id but on the other hand samsung
decided to go with the
in display fingerprint sensor right here
and just using it like that
it should work there you go and unlocked
and i'd say that i definitely prefer
face id because it kind of happens
passively
whereas with this you have to pick it up
and you gotta use your finger i think it
takes a little bit more time
now one thing that's very unique about
the m1 ipad pro is that it comes with a
12 megapixel
ultra wide selfie camera the quality is
really really good but apple is going to
be using a center stage feature
where crops in and kind of follows your
face so let me know how the microphone
sounds as well on this ipad pro
and now on the samsung you guys can see
that this is definitely a more cropped
in shot just like the old ipad pro
but you guys let me know what you think
about the quality as well as the
microphone
down in the comments below now the last
thing i want to mention before we get
into the speaker comparison
is the difference in the battery sizes
the samsung tab
s7 plus has a 39.04 watt hour battery
compared to 40.88 watt hours on the ipad
pro
so this is almost two watt hours larger
and as you can see
we're at 100 battery life on the ipad
pro and now
down to 97 on the tab s7 which is
interesting
and now let's get into that speaker
comparison and of course i'm gonna
enable dolby atmos on the samsung
and we switched the song to a new one
and you guys were complaining
so let's bring back the original and
classic where we started
me song for watching
let me know what you think about the
sound quality down in the comment
section below
but to me i was very surprised by the
volume of the samsung because
the 12.9 inch ipad pro is much louder
than the 11 inch m1 ipad pro
and the samsung is even louder than the
12.9 in so this volume is really
impressive
but one thing i noticed on the ipad pro
is that it has more kind of deep
bass as well as deeper and louder mids
compared to the samsung which
had a lot of high notes and now let's
get into the performance comparison
starting with geekbench 5 and as you
guys can see we have the m1 chip running
at 3.2 gigahertz with 8 gigabytes of
memory
and right here we have the snapdragon
865 plus
and we made sure to get the higher end
eight gigabyte ram model
on the tab because the base model only
comes with six
whereas with the m1 ipad pro you can
actually get up to 16 gigs of ram
and we actually did a full comparison
video comparing an 8 gig and 16 gig
model which was very interesting so if
you haven't already seen that
definitely watch that video and with
that let's go ahead and run
the cpu benchmark all right we got our
scores and oh my goodness guys i cannot
believe
this difference we have 76
more single core performance on the ipad
pro and wait for it
2.4 times more multi-core performance
i cannot believe this difference now
that is probably why the ipad pro
is so much more expensive but we're
gonna get into prices in just a bit now
of course that was a heavy benchmark so
let's test something that everybody does
on their tablets
and that's web browsing this is
speedometer 2.0 a web browsing benchmark
which is going to show the real world i
guess web browsing performance that
you're going to get with each one so
let's start it no way guys i was not
expecting these scores
210 on the ipad pro and only 67.3
on the samsung i was not expecting a
score that low i thought it'd be like
maybe somewhere in the hundreds but 67
to 210 that's over three
times better for browsing performance on
the ipad pro
and now let's get into the big graphics
test
3dmark's brand new wildlife
extreme benchmark we're going to do
unlimited
on both of these to see how the graphics
performance
compares the benchmark is now finished
and
guys i thought that 2.4 times more
multi-core performance was a lot
this right here is insane 29.8 fps on
the ipad pro
compared to 7.2 fps on the tab
s7 plus that is over four times the fps
and i was thinking of doing a gaming
performance comparison
between these two tablets but at this
point i don't even think it's worth it
and now
let's finally answer the biggest
question that we had
did apple make a mistake by using mini
led
instead of just going to oled like the
samsung
first of all i want to mention that the
samsung has a 12.4 inch display compared
to 12.9 inches
but as you can see the surface area is
much larger on the ipad pro and that is
because of the difference in the aspect
ratio
we have a four by three aspect ratio on
the ipad and a 16
by 10 on the samsung which means it is
taller
and it doesn't have as much surface area
now in terms of the resolution
they're both pretty similar we have 266
ppi
on the samsung and 264 on the ipad pro
now both of these have 120 hertz panels
that means they're going to be super
smooth
compared to more budget tablets now one
of the main benefits with mini led is
that it can get a lot
brighter than oled specifically up to
1600 nits when you're watching
hdr content but when you're just using
it as a regular tablet and doing common
things
it's going to be limited to around 600
nits of brightness
so let's max it out and see how bright
the samsung's oled gets
as you guys can see right here we have
both of them fully maxed out let's go to
google
and from that top camera you guys should
be able to see that the ipad pro
is quite a bit brighter and one
interesting thing that we notice
is that the split second that you go
from regular page to a full screen white
page
the display on the samsung actually dims
down a little bit because oled
can't really handle full screen
brightness that well but one advantage
that you do get with an oled display is
better viewing angle so i'm going to
match the brightness
and then we're going to see the
difference in i guess brightness shift
so if you go ahead and look at the side
camera you should be able to see that
the samsung holds its brightness better
when viewing at it from the side
compared to the ipad pro which starts to
dim down a little bit
and another thing i'm noticing from my
view right here is that the colors on
the ipad pro
actually shift over to a blue tint so
i'm going to try to show you guys in the
top camera
you can see how the display goes from
white
to blue so that's definitely an issue
with this display
and now let's move on to comparing the
contrast because throughout this video i
noticed that the contrast on the samsung
didn't look that great for some reason
so what i want to do
is open up a pure black youtube video
and compare them and if you look at that
top camera
for some reason the display on the
samsung looks a little bit gray
where it should be pure black because
the pixels are literally off
but the ipad pro has much deeper blacks
and i think the reason for that is
actually because of the reflectivity on
the samsung
even if you look at the bezels the
bezels on the samsung don't look as
deep black so let's compare the
reflectivity so if you look at the side
camera the samsung almost looks like a
mirror like you could see
so much detail whereas with the ipad pro
everything's deep and dark
and it's hard to see like even in the
blues they're much darker than on the
samsung
and now what i have right here is an hdr
video on youtube
this is the lg oled test it's designed
to show off the benefits of oled so it
should give
the samsung an advantage so let's go
ahead and watch this
alright guys to my eyes this is insane
because the samsung
almost looks like an lcd display because
those
blacks are not black they are gray
because of that reflectivity issue this
right here on the ipad pro looks amazing
now i'm not going to get into the
blooming stuff yet i'm going to talk
about that in just a minute but
this difference is insane i don't
understand
why samsung gave this tablet such a
reflective display
if they were going to put in an oled
panel because
it kind of ruins it and the thing is
this room isn't even that bright
to show reflectivity that bad so i guess
we're going to have to turn off
all of the lights and see what these
displays are going to look like and see
if we get any blooming on the mini led
display and now that the lights are off
the reflectivity is no longer an issue
on the samsung but man that mini led
is crazy crazy bright and because of the
brightness the mini led display looks
much more like
hdr because the highlights can really
pop compared to the samsung which looks
a little bit more flat
and as far as blooming looking at from
my angle that icon right there
i could definitely see a little bit of
gray around it but in general
in these bright scenes you really can't
tell even in this one
you can't really tell with the blooming
and wow that waterfall is really popping
on the ipad pro but now to really test
the blooming i'm gonna put the ipad pro
through the most
extreme scenario all the lights off
brightness set to the max
and then let's switch to a different
video alright so i have an hdr fireworks
video with pitch black which is the
hardest scenario and with these controls
open
i'm seeing a lot of blooming on the
minute led display especially up here
where that title is and on the samsung
it just looks so
clean and now watching this video you
can definitely see that blooming
especially right here
on the left side with those buildings
you're seeing that
glow around it whereas the oled on the
samsung
man that looks so clean that contrast
is really really good but keep in mind
this is the most extreme scenario we
maxed out the display all the way and in
most movies you're not gonna have
blacks like this very rarely you're
gonna have such an extreme scenario so
now we turned on just one of our lights
and it's definitely dim in this room
but that major difference is no longer
that big because that reflectivity is
reintroduced on the samsung
and the blooming doesn't look so bad i
can still tell if i look closely but
it's definitely not as bad as it was in
pitch black and now with all of that
said and compared let's get into the
final
verdict the 12.9 inch m1 ipad pro cost
270 dollars more than the samsung
but if you do want to get the apple
pencil the tab seven gets it
included so that makes it a 400
difference
spec for spec now initially we thought
that was quite a bit
more expensive and maybe not worth the
price
but now that we've compared it and saw
those crazy performance gains
and saw that the mini led display is
definitely quite good especially with
that really nice anti-reflectivity
coating
i actually think that it's worth paying
the extra money
for the ipad pro and to answer the
original question
did apple make a mistake by going with
mini led well if you're mainly buying a
tablet to use at night for watching
movies
then yes oled is definitely better but
for most scenario and most common use
cases
i'd have to say that mini led is the
better choice
so hopefully you guys enjoyed this
comparison and if you did go ahead and
comment down below
and click that circle but to subscribe
for more comparisons like this one
definitely watch one of those two videos
right there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video